this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for inviting me up to
New York love love New York love the
pika before we get started I know we've
got some at least one retailer right
how many growers are in the audience
okay landscapers couple educators master
gardeners Wow okay
really good okay well I'm very pleased
to talk to you about pollinators because
it's an extremely important topic and we
can all week indefinitely help
listening to carol was very helpful to
see you know where is our gardening
public going and who do we need to reach
out to just coming about three weeks ago
from the international pollinator
conference at Penn State I can tell you
that the pollinator crisis is very real
and it's something that we have to
adjust worldwide I think the good news
is that all of us here working in the
screen industry can be part of the
solution and again listening to Carol I
was thinking about the connection with
kids I mean what's the more wonderful
connection than plants butterflies bees
you know things that move because kids
love this kind of thing and food
gardening it it's a perfect match so
what I want to do I'm going to kind of
take you through a quick introduction
for those of you who might not be
terribly familiar with pollinators we're
going to talk about who they are gonna
talk about the stressors on them and
then the important part what can we do
to help them with our floral resources
okay so most of you guys know this why
our pollinators important well we like
to eat we like to eat watermelon we like
to eat squash we like to eat blueberries
and apples and these are all things that
are insect pollinated so without these
our diets become very bland we also have
an economic value going on here without
pollinators we have definitely have some
economic problems and then there's the
ecosystem without pollination of plants
we have no seeds we have no berries
which means we have no
food web and everything really does
collapse which is why we call
pollinators keystone species we cannot
pull these guys out and still have all
of us survive so I think when you're
gardening for pollinators when you're
thinking about plants for them it's
important to know who our pollinators
are because it's not just honeybees it's
a very very wide range of diversity and
each of these guys use something just a
little bit different so flies
I know flies aren't a big sell to the
public but some of them are actually
quite beautiful the serf would fly over
here on the left some kind sometimes
also called hover fly very frequent
flower visitors and they do their share
of pollination and as a bonus their
larvae are wonderful Aoife deters so
we've got beneficial insects going on
here too this tack Ned fly not quite as
pretty over on the left or excuse me on
your right this tacna fly is actually
very important because it's the
parasitoid of the brown marmorated stink
bug lays its eggs on them so these
pollinators that are visiting these
plants have more benefit than just
moving pollen and nectar or moving
pollen beetles very frequent flower
visitors I can't tell you how many
people bring these into the office after
they've killed them because they've said
they're on my flowers and must be doing
something bad
but this soldier beetle is actually
another beneficial and you know it
actually does eat some aphids and as a
flower visitor it's moving some pollen
butterflies and moths easy sell
maybe poster child for pollinators not
as efficient because their legs hold
them above the flowers so they're not
moving around as much pollen but they're
absolutely beautiful they have they
definitely have another role in the
environment and that's your caterpillars
feeding Birds which is supporting the
whole food web but when we're talking to
people about pollinators sometimes this
is the way to get them and
pollinator gardening because who doesn't
love butterflies and of course birds
another very beloved pollinator I would
think that Cardinal flower and the speed
bomb monarda would be very very very
easy to sell we find that in our in our
master gardener plant sales because
people want to support these beautiful
birds and then we get into the
Hymenoptera the wasps and the bees and
yes if you have pollinator friendly
plants you are going to have a lot of
lost most of them are solitary they're
not the yellow jacket type social wasp
they're solitary the the females doing
all of her work she's far too busy to
even even think about singing a lot of
these are ground nesters this is
actually one we've been doing some work
on at our pollinator plot this is by
surtees she is a ground nester and
during her lifetime which is very short
she can kill 40 or kill and take back to
the nest 40 brown marmorated stink bugs
so you know very there's the flower
visitors but they're also performing
other functions for us and then there's
the bees these are our main pollinators
there's no doubt about that
all the bees are very effective at
pollination because they are collecting
pollen these other visitors are strictly
getting nectar and kind of accidentally
moving things with them these guys have
to collect pollen to take back to the
nest to feed their larvae the PB young
and they're very well adapted for it
with their bodies and pollen collectors
everybody's familiar with honeybees but
not everybody knows that honeybees are
actually a farm to be they're not
considered wild they were brought over
from Europe with the Jamestown settlers
and it's been an economic farm product
ever since what folks aren't too
familiar with it's an 80 phase and we
have a lot of them before these honeys
bees were brought over pollination was
happening here we
a great ecosystem going and there are
over 20,000 species worldwide right here
in the mid-atlantic region we figured in
Pennsylvania we have about 450 we're
discovering new species every day
because until we had the problem with
pollinators nobody was doing a whole lot
of studying and so now with everything
being geared up we are learning a lot
and these species are very very varied
there's all kinds of bees out there
bumble bees most people are familiar
with they are a social be the queen
actually has workers in a small colony
in the ground maybe 250 of them and then
these other bees are solitary again the
Queen is doing all of her own work
she might only be laying 1012 eggs she
might be laying them in the ground in
hollow stems she might be using dead
wood so all of these nesting sites
become extremely important and these
bees vary from the pretty large
carpenter bee down to the tiny little
sweat bee that is really difficult to
identify when they're on the flowers but
there are a lot of them out there
we have bees that are specialists and
this is important when we're thinking
about what we're planting the squash bee
on the on your left over here actually
nests underneath squash plants and you
don't need honeybees if you're growing
squash because you if you plant it they
will come if you're farming practices
are not disturbing their nests they will
be there for you the male's fall asleep
in the flowers they're very very sweet
and they take care of your your crop for
you it's an 80 feet the mining be on the
right I put in here because there is a
particular mining bee that is a
specialist on goldenrod that the way it
collects pollen and its collectors only
fit one size of pollen grain and that's
from goldenrod or aster
and so without goldenrod or Astor those
bees are gone so these specialists fees
are not as common but they have a very
important niche and we need to keep the
diversity so they're very important
other bees have a really wide floral
range can bumble bee easier this way
this wonderful little leafcutter bee can
go from one species to another and and
actually visit many many different
families of flowers and we need we need
both of these groups the bad news is
pollinators are declining and it's a
rather steep decline it's happening
quickly we have about 34 animals and
identified as pollinators that are
endangered or threatened and then look
at the number of flowering species that
are also endangered or threatened and
the relationship between the flowers and
their pollinators is very tight so
sometimes if you lose a flower a floral
resource you're going to lose a
pollinator and vice versa so this is a
concerning issue this last winter
honeybees declined again these are our
farmed bees they lost 45 percent 15
percent losses what they normally would
expect and this has been going on now
for quite a few years ever since we've
heard about the colony collapse disorder
our wild bees are also in trouble we
might never have known this if Colony
Collapse hadn't happened with the
honeybees we may never have actually
started to study these other bees but
we've got at least five species of our
North American bumble bees that are are
shrinking and range and part of this is
due to climate change there's a lot of
other reasons as well 13 out of 46
species of our bumblebees are now
threatened or near threatened this is
not good news because the bumble bee
globally is
second most important pollinator of
crops second only to that that have
farmed honeybee that's being taken
around and then butterflies Wow
141 different species at risk course the
latest one that everybody knows about is
is the monarch right so what in the
world is going on with our pollinators
what is stressing them out so much well
there is no one smoking-gun through this
it's hard to do research on these
wonderful you know wonderful creatures
because there's so many factors coming
in we know that habitat nutrition is one
pesticide exposure we've got diseases
viruses of fun fungus is out there
perhaps genetics we know that climate
change is is playing a role and when
these all come together it's somewhat of
a recipe for disaster I'm going to talk
about these two the pesticides and the
nutrition because these are things we
can do something about the rest of this
we have to kind of leave to the
researchers and habitat loss is huge
both of nesting habitat
you know they can't nest and mops they
can't nest and thick turf so our
gardening practices are kind of against
them and we've fragmented our landscapes
so much that some of these insects can't
fly across some of the the more urban
areas that we've created and noted
ecologist down in Arizona has determined
over 95% of the land in the lower 48
states is either in agriculture or
development that doesn't leave a whole
lot for our pollinator friends and our
farming practices in the Midwest have
changed drastically and we know this is
this is a definite problem for
pollinators these vast fields of
monocultures know hedgerows you know
pollinator strips you know there's just
nothing there for the pollinators here
in the Northeast we're a little better
off because our farms are smaller
still do have head shows we've got you
know forest lands in between and so
we're definitely we're definitely better
here than in the Midwest our suburban
areas are the other part of this as
natural fields and forests are plowed
down or taken down for our development
for homes and businesses what we put
back in our yards does not begin to
satisfy the needs of the pollinators our
turf are our plants which we're
importing mostly from other countries
just not a lot there and even our
campuses as beautiful as our own Penn
State campus is when I walk around I see
a lot of places where you know we could
we could do better and we could be
putting in more floral resources we
could be filming this stuff with flowers
wouldn't that be wonderful we fill
everything with flowers a lot of the
natural lands that are left have been
overrun with invasives and I know you
have a talk on that a little bit later
this is a national state state forest in
Pennsylvania which is being overrun by
japanese stiltgrass and japanese barbary
that has escaped from our yards and once
you get that kind of monoculture in the
forest crowding out a lot of the the
wild flowers our pollinators have
trouble pesticides are a tough issue and
I'm not an expert on pesticides it's
kind of relay to you what our Center for
pollinator research has found so far we
know that pesticides are part of this
whole problem we also know that whatever
we put down pollinators pick up and in a
study back around 2007 we of pollen
samples we found out that they were 121
different pesticides identified in wax
and pollen samples from honeybees so if
we if we put it out there picking it up
so what are those there's a lot they
were very few samples that didn't have
anything in them and of 121 different
ones here is a list of some of the
categories you see some very familiar
pesticides there that's a good question
I'm not a hundred percent sure what
percentage but we can find that out oh
yes I'm sorry she asked what percentage
of the samples did not have any
detections it says very few but I don't
have that actual percentage okay we have
systemics out there that are getting
into pollen and connector and they're
getting them the pollinators are getting
them that way and her pollen sample each
one had an average of six different
pesticides so it's it's really it was
very eye-opening for our researchers to
see this of the of the entire you know I
don't know how many samples they looked
at again the Center for pollinator
research we can get that from them how
many samples they sampled
Oh hurt well whether whether they were
yeah whether they were looking at pound
and wax they were looking at him both
together
yeah for the systemics yeah and yeah
really good
go ahead would would be present right
right right
it's a very very good question and I
apologize I don't have all of those
answers but Mary Anne Frazier who was
our researcher at Penn State that did
this
she has since retired but these this is
all available at Penn State and if you
guys want that I can try to get like to
try to get more of the total study for
you so you'd have an idea of what all
the parameters were okay
okay it sounds good the other thing I
just wanted to bring to your attention
is there are different there are
different modes of action of these
pesticides with the pollinators lethal
means carbaryl is a good example seven
you spray it they die so that's lethal
they immediately die but there are
sub-lethal effects as well so of the
four that are listed here reduced immune
function reduced lifespan impaired
foraging behavior reproduce reproduction
which one do you think would be a sub
lethal effect all of them you're right
and this is a difficult thing to study
but there are many many studies out
there on this and so oftentimes when
they're exposed to these pesticides you
don't get an outright kill but they are
impaired in such a way that the colony
eventually you know is affected or the
individuals may die okay so all of the
above
just a quick word about nyan X and again
I'm I my X my expertise is in the plants
not so much in pesticides but they have
found sub-lethal effects from the neo
NEX and impaired foraging behavior the
decreased reproduction and so the
recommendation that is coming out is
don't use neo next prophylactically and
if you're growing a lot of the plants
that we're going to be talking about in
a few minutes there's no need to be
using anything in them because these
plants are tough and so wherever you can
especially with pollinator plants try to
stay away from from any kind of systemic
they also discovered that fungicides
play a role here which few d complicates
things especially for the orchard folks
and the fungicides can actually
synergize with some of the insecticides
per tick
the three listed here and become
stronger we also don't know what the
inert ingredients of the pesticides do
and there are some researchers looking
at that
what is in those in their ingredients we
need to find that out and how can they
affect pollinators so with the
pesticides it's complicated it's very
complicated
herbicides play a role too in that by
strainer roadsides or medians tricks you
know we're killing off a lot of our
floral resources reducing habitat in our
lawns violets are a good early season
source of nectar for bees host plant for
the fritillary butterfly clover which
used to be a mainstay in our lawns back
you know my grandfather always seeded
clover into his lawn but today in this
generation clover is a weed we've kind
of made it that way but clover is a
wonderful source for for bees you know
so the herbicides can can do some damage
to us too so just in general these are
some of the recommendations that the
center came out with for protecting
pollinators from pesticides you know
know know what you're using know how
toxic it is sometimes sometimes that's
not so easy because what's toxic to a
honeybee might not be toxic to a
bumblebee vice versa it's it's
complicated but never use pesticides on
blooming crops and then pre bloom don't
use the systemics because some of these
can linger in the plant for a long time
that's bad news but there's good news
and that this international conference
this last this last month the one theme
that came through of so many of the
papers was that even in the presence of
diseases and in the presence of
pesticides if these pollinators were
well fed if they had good nutrition
they could fight off some of this some
of these effects and it's no different
from us you know if we're rundown we
don't have a good diet we don't have a
diverse diet yeah where we can easily
get pick up a cold pick up a flu pick up
anything and they're no different and so
we can really make a difference even in
the face of the other things they're
facing by giving them a diverse diet by
giving them what they really need the
best possible nectar the best possible
pollen we can dilute some of these these
compounds and dilute the effects of some
of the diseases so to me I kind of came
away from the from that conference
feeling like yes what we do and how the
green industry responds to this really
can make a huge difference I had a good
news is the gardener's that I talked to
are aware they know they're kind of tied
into this and those new gardeners that
Kara was talking about they want their
kids they want their kids to be tied in
they know that we have some
environmental problems going on here and
they're anxious for the kids to learn
and what a wonderful learning
opportunity that could be paired with
you know with our garden centers these
guys are hungry and providing food is
also a very feel-good thing for all of
us
it can also be lucrative
Michigan State just did a study this was
actually on the labeling of plants
treated with pesticides and the study
found that plants that were labeled be
friendly as being grown in a bee
friendly way we're much preferred by the
consumers so people are responding to
this they want to help they also found
out
that people are willing to pay a little
more for a plant that was grown in a
beef friendly way got up to a dollar
more so there's an opportunity there as
well and I'm I'm assuming because of how
consumers are reacting that they would
react the same way to not just plants
that were grown in a pollinator friendly
way but growing plants that are truly
really nutritious and good for
pollinators
I think the labeling of these plants
would would definitely be helpful and
there's all kinds of things you could do
in a garden center to you know to make
that attractive but the big question is
what are the best pollinator plants and
we are still trying to answer that
question we're getting closer
we know that some of our modern hybrids
that are being developed especially in
the annual world and a being developed
for color or size or you know just
appeal may or may not have pollen or
nectar
sometimes the nectaries are bred out of
the plants through the pollen is bred
out of it sometimes the plant can become
so complicated and structure that the
pollinator has no idea how to get to the
pollen that's there if you look at our
native plants they are they have been
they've been co-evolved to actually
attract pollinators and some have I like
to show you something here some have
guidelines
I mean summer just saying hey guys your
pollinators may not be too smart here
this is where you come and a plant like
this it's a little confusing so down at
our Penn State Research Station near
where I live in Landis ville where we
have our flower trials the Center for
pollinator research has set up a row for
pollinator insect study and they've
taken some of the most common good
sellers at garden centers
and the researchers from the study are
coming down and evaluating them for
politic pollinator visitation which I'm
really glad they're doing this because
we need to know and it's nothing wrong
with having a plant in your garden that
doesn't attract pollinators but we also
need to be including plants that do
attract pollinators we need to know what
they are we do know from our studies
that most native perennials are good
pollinator plants yeah that's kind of
what they chose you know when
availability was part of was part of the
issue too when they did that but and as
they go forward they're going to target
you know specific plants a little bit
more and try to see what what are the
best sellers out there what are people
buying and how can we label these things
most native perennial plants we know are
good for pollinators because they
co-evolved together without their
pollinators these plants wouldn't have
made it through but when we change them
and we create cultivars from them what
happens on the left is a straight
species of of echinacea or confit and
boy you know pollinator heaven on the
right here's another one in our child
and I haven't spent much time over there
looking but the few times that I've been
over I haven't seen any pollinators on
that guy and it's because we've we've
changed it is is anything still there
these are things we need to find out
Mount Cuba's doing some great studies
down at the University of with with the
University of Delaware and dr. Delaney
and one of her grad students Owen Cass
have been looking at menardes and
coreopsis and trying to determine which
ones of these are attracting pollinators
they're even looking at the nectar
they're analyzing the nectar you know
what does it have does it have the
proteins in the
but does it have what pollinators really
need and they're looking at a lot of
cultivars so if you ever get down there
it's a really neat place to visit and
they do have some reports out they were
also just looking at the plants
themselves know which ones are the most
attractive which ones hold up the best
so this pollinator study is now a little
addition to all of this and these
reports are online
this is their coreopsis report Owens
should be putting his monarda report out
pretty soon and then lastly we did a
trial study at our Research Station 2012
to 2014 where we looked at 84 different
species of native plants and their
cultivars and these were replicated in
five by five plots three times and we
had Master Gardeners helping us with
this as well as as well as our
researchers so before I go into the
results of that study which is what your
handout is all about for those of you
that are landscapers just wanted to
mention a few things about how we can
make some changes in our landscaping to
help out the pollinators
here are three properties very different
in size the one on the top is about 35
acres got Meadow it's all been
landscaping native plants then
professionally done and even the pool
area I mean this is a wonderful floral
resource for pollinators but down on the
bottom left is a small garden in the
City of York postage stamp-sized but
look what she's done she has put a lot
of wonderful floral resources in there
still has a little bit of lawn but she's
beauti year-round or well three seasons
and then on the right this is a nursing
home also in York County where they have
taken grass and they've turned it into a
therapeutic place for their their
residents
a place of beauty a place alive with
pollinators that the residents are
lining up to get into this nursing home
because they want to be able to look out
on this this wonderful courtyard so size
doesn't matter every space that we have
can be utilized but what all three of
these places hadn't have in common is
they have put plants closer together
we have plants touching each other
reduced use of mulch and landscape
fabric because the nesting they can't
nest with landscape fabric and so by by
packing in our plants letting them touch
letting them be a little bit more
natural weed free there's no space there
for weeds to grow so that's a really big
help as well
there's still maintenance obviously but
it's a different different kind of
maintenance so think about that in
really large areas landscape plugs can
be very helpful yeah
and negative a couple of things one is
if if you plate spacing plants you know
two three feet apart would have a need
for mulch you don't have many floral
resources you have weeds you're gonna
have weeds growing down through that
that mulch nesting sites become limited
because bees can't the ground nesters
can't can't go down through the mulch or
the landscape fabric yeah so and it's
also a cost saver I talked to a group
that said they had spent fifteen
thousand dollars for their homeowners
association on March last year and I'm
thinking but they were wondering how
they could get more flowers and I said
well take that fifteen thousand dollars
and maybe maybe move it over so yeah
those two things are kind of a negative
when we're talking about about
pollinators this is actually the front
of my house so landscape plugs are a
really cost-effective way to do this if
your landscaping they can be a dollar a
piece there are native plant wholesalers
that are growing these guys they're
struggling to keep up because there's a
demand so anybody looking for a niche
market maybe might be a place to go
these plugs can also be purchased and
potted up in two quarts and sold at
garden centers so there is a source for
these plants there are also seed sources
out there a lot of people are collecting
mobile appetites and also when you're
placing these diversity is really key I
told you that plants pollinators and
their plants are closely related
look at this penstemon I mean Espenson
men isn't letting anything to chance
here's a landing pad for the bumble bee
guidelines hey guys
that's the way to go right and each of
these plants is going to attract a
different kind of pollinator because
they all have different sized tongues
and different needs so diversity is
great planning we're trying to get
people to plant in groups and jeff's
because one single plant
going to help a pollinator too much and
you know they'll see a mass much better
and have plants to move between
succession of bloom plants from spring
through fall there are different kinds
of bees emerging in march and the whole
way through the season until the first
really hard frost they all need food so
picking a succession of bloom it also
means hey we're getting more plants out
there
we're selling more plants we're we're
enjoying more plants we're seeing more
color in the landscape so here are the
results of the 84 species that we did
you have the full results on your on
your papers i'm only going to touch on a
few of these plants for the sake of time
in general we discovered that plants
with large compound inflorescences of
tiny flowers attracted more different
kinds of pollinators than other flowers
this is where we got our diversity so
think swamp milkweed over here on the
left
phone-sex in the middle which is one of
the eupatorium the jhope eyes there are
many many flowers out there that have
these kind of flower heads they're not
the only thing you should plant but you
know if you're trying to get a plant to
a new gardener see biggest bang for
their buck these are the way to go and
then I'm going to start with my number
one winner right off the top pick nan
from mu to come the custard mountain man
is anybody growing this you are lots of
pollinators yeah Apple mint the mint
family in general the mint found me the
Aster family are both huge families for
pollinators and this is a native mint
but yes other mints you know Woods will
do well too if she left them flower and
this clustered Mountain mint was was a
plant that we felt could be a gorgeous
plant for the garden as well as valuable
for pollinators smells wonderful we had
21 different kinds of pollinators
visited from butterflies to flies to
beetles to bees to wasps it seemed as
though if you you could tell where it
was in the child plot because there was
a species over the top of it and I
actually had one educator come visit our
plot and we we talked about the plot
before we went in he told me later if
you hadn't told me that that was a good
thing I would have made a big berth
around that planet
he said cuz there was so much stuff on
it but but he said now I know it's it's
a good thing it's a good thing so we
need some education too
it only grows about 3 to 4 feet tall
does like some soil moisture it's not
not a plant for real dry soils it had an
advantage over the other plants because
it bloomed for ten weeks and so you know
we were counting pollinators for a lot
longer and one of the best juices I've
seen for this plant was at Irvine Nature
Center this is a parking lot divider and
the only downside to having that was
when people were getting in their cars
with their purchases they know they
would get they would get their cameras
out and they'd be taking pictures of
buckeyes and all kinds of take him 20
minutes to get out of the parking lot
and I have to say in the three years
were five years now about master
gardeners about 20 of them have been
working in this trial plot there's been
not a single sting these guys are too
busy only the females can sting of the
lost and the bees because it's the
ovipositor that's a stinger the male's
can sting guess who has time on their
hands the males
the females are doing all the work
they've they've got to get the nectar
they have a short period of time they've
got to get the palm they've got to feed
the kids they could care less about you
the males are kind of hanging around and
being a little aggressive but it can't
hurt you okay goldenrods
I would like to rhinocam time five
minutes okay I would love to see anybody
here growing golden nuts yes not why all
the golden rods are an extremely
important plant it really tied for
number one with that mountain mint this
is this is stiff goldenrod butterflies
loved it
we're doing a project with the Xerces
Society right now to find out what
nectar plants the monarch is using on
its check from Canada to Mexico and
they're strongly suspecting that
goldenrod has historically always been
one of the fuels to help them get down
to their wintering grounds so they're
extremely important and we had so many
butterflies on this plant it really
stands up very tall and will withstand
some some medium to dry soils it's
blooming as we speak
and just attracts so many different
pollinators would be great for back of
the border it does seat around after
five years we're learning which plants
they'd in place and which ones didn't
and in some places seating around would
be great in the case of a homeowner they
might not like it so much
so hey I've got another goldenrod for
you fireworks this one just kind of
grows out from a center patch and forms
a larger patch easy to take care of you
divide it and you can keep it in check
it's all the golden odds were very good
for pollinators and I would love to
dispel the fact that people think that
goldenrod is as an allergen I hear that
all the time
it's insect pollinated pounds heavy it
does not get carried by land insects
move it it is not an allergen rag
is the is the the carpet and when I went
to England last fall I saw more girl
than not in garden of Derby there than I
ever see here they have a love affair
with it they shouldn't because it's
become invasive for them because they
don't have know they don't have the
ecosystem built around it but this is
Shakespeare's birthplace just amazing
use of goldenrod they love it they're
selling it back to us by the way and
here's their award another wonderful
wonderful pollinator plant attracted a
lot of those those parasitoids at the
brown marmorated stink bug very easy to
grow plant likes likes dry soil and full
Sun none of these native plants ever
need fertilizer ever fact fertilizer is
counterproductive to them they are
adapted for nutrient poor soils the
jokai I can't say enough about these and
they all of them were wonderful plants
even all the cultivars all the straight
species did very very well I singled out
dubium because it was our number one
plant for attracting butterflies we over
three years we had 17 different
butterflies and skippers on it it was
the last one to bloom it's actually it
is actually a plant of the coastal plain
it's the shortest shortest of all the
joke eyes which is always popular with
homeowners
mycology apprise average to moist soil
and it is just beginning to bloom now
swamp milkweed if you have a garden
center milkweeds are so popular at our
plant sales at our office we we could
hardly get them
the berries are having trouble keeping
them in stock because everybody knows
about the monarch and everybody wants to
help even common milkweed is flying off
the shelves the swamp milkweed is a
great plant for all kinds of pollinators
including a good nectar plant for the
monarch and they love to lay their eggs
on this
so but it does need more soil there are
other milk weeds that can be grown that
need other other conditions was a
milkweed for everybody
rattlesnake master a pretty cool plant
this is anybody bearing this one I know
this one this was a bit of a surprise to
us I was a little surprised to see how
good it was as a pollinator plant but
all those tiny little flowers were
attracting a lot of different diversity
and it's a very cool plant the kids love
it and I was interested to see that at
the new formal garden by the mansion at
Mount cuba's center they had
incorporated rattlesnake master into
their garden as a structural element so
it's really very cool and then a few
comparisons do we have time for this
today there are a lot of comparisons and
you have the cultivars sheet there for
for all of them here are just a few
examples we looked at the straight
species of monarda mr. Moser against
Clare grace and what we discovered is
that the straight species was very much
preferred don't know what it is about
Clare grace that the butterflies are
they the bees didn't didn't prefer it
but and maybe it was just just the fact
that we had so much food available okay
but this this you'll see on your sheets
is a terrific plant for pollinators six
different kinds of bumble bees on here
hummingbird Maas and you plant it with
other plants so that if it does get
powdery mildew you don't notice it you
put it with its friends
here's another cultivar comparison
between the aromatic asters three
different kinds and in this case you'll
see that the cause of our October skies
was preferred we were surprised to see
that but it actually did better and it's
a shorter variety than the straight
speed
these and did not seem to see it around
very much which was kind of a fuss too
and then we looked at coreopsis three
different types of coreopsis including
the straight species and after three
years dad grabbed had done better
possibly because it was it was I've had
more flowers on it than the straight
species but what was interesting we're
five years into this we're not counting
pollinators only plants any longer but
the plants are still in the in the child
and after five years
Zagreb is starting to fade under the
weed pressure at the farm because we can
you know I only have twenty master
gardeners and trying to get all these
weeds out of there is interesting so
we've kind of left moon being go it just
isn't it's still there but it doesn't
have the vigour Zagreb is fading a
little bit but the straight species we
don't have to do much to so it's it's
just interesting watching what happens
over time with these plants and I wanted
to give a shout out to this particular
plant monarda Peters fancy Keisha we're
not a hundred percent sure of the
parentage of this plant if somebody
knows that I'd like to know what it is
but in our child it was a favorite of
bumblebees and they would hang on to it
to the very last but you know last
flower so just about was ready to fall
off and in our trials has really held up
under all this weed pressure so I just
feel it's a really good garden plan the
other thing that came out of this trial
is a phenology chart we kept track of
the bloom for a couple of years this is
not in your handout or on the website
but if you wanted I can send it to you
it's you know prints large because it's
84 different species but it's a really
handy thing to have if you want to think
about planting that succession of bloom
and they were really I mean all the pot
all the plants in our plot did pretty
well if you want to see the full report
you can go to the Center for pollinator
research website just google it go to
the pollinator garden certification this
is a Master Gardener program and under
step one provide food for pollinators
there will be a link to bees vibes and
blooms and I have a card up here with
the website on it if you're interested
so hopefully together I mean what it's
this is a feel-good thing because
getting plants out there and and getting
plants in the hands of people and kids
is great Wow helping pollinators at the
same time is even better so you know
correctively I think we can make a real
difference thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu